TAKES THIS WORKING-CLASS
NARRATIVE, MAYBE RIGHT UP TILL
2020.
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
WE ARE GOING TO UNPACK THE
REASONS FOR THIS RATINGS BONANZA
AND ARE SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT
COMING UP WITH RAYMOND ARROYO,
BUT MEANWHILE, THE CONSERVATIVE
ENCLAVE OF ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA HAS JUST BECOME THE
EPICENTER OF THE FIGHT OVER THE
SANCTUARY STATE POLICY.
YESTERDAY IN AN AMAZING MOVE,
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED TO CONDEMN
CALIFORNIA SANCTUARY LAW AND IS
NOW JOINING A U.S. JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT LAWSUIT THAT CLAIMS
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM OUT THERE IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
JOINING US NOW WITH THE REACTION
IS ORANGE COUNTY SUPERVISOR
MICHELLE STEELE, A LEGAL
IMMIGRANT WHO, GET THIS, WAS
CALLED A RACIST B WORD OVER HER
WILLINGNESS TO COOPERATE WITH
I.C.E., ALONG WITH A FORMER
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE COMMISSIONER.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
LET'S START WITH YOU, MICHELE.
WHEN I READ WHAT THEY SAID ABOUT
YOU WITH YOUR BACKGROUND, I'D
LIKE TO SAY I WAS SURPRISED, BUT
I WASN'T, BECAUSE IF YOU BOOK
THE LIBERAL TREND IN CALIFORNIA
ON AN ISSUE LIKE IMMIGRATION,
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE FREE
LICENSE TO CALL YOU ANY NAME IN
THE BOOK.
TELL US HOW YOUR LIFE HAS BEEN
IN THE 24 HOURS SINCE THIS
DECISION WAS MADE.
>> COME MY GOD.
I'M VERY HAPPY ABOUT IT BECAUSE
I WAS
THE ONE THAT ACTUALLY INTRODUCED
THE RESOLUTION, BECAUSE OUR
LOCAL POLICE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES, THEIR
HANDS HAD BEEN TIED, SO WE
REALLY HAVE TO WORK BECAUSE, AS
THE SUPERVISOR, ORANGE COUNTY
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMES FIRST.
BECAUSE IT IS INTERESTING, YOU
CAN HEAR THAT I SPEAK KOREAN,
JAPANESE IS MY SECOND LANGUAGE,
ENGLISH IS MY THIRD.
I WENT THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS
AS A LEGAL IMMIGRANT, AND I WAS
CALLED RACIST B, WHEN YOU GET
CALLED THESE NAMES, YOU HAVE A
LONG LINE, , LIFE, SO I'M GOINGT
LONG LINE, , LIFE, SO I'M GOINGO
HAVE A LONG LIFE.
>> Laura: I KNOW YOU DON'T
SUPPORT CALLING MICHELE NAMES,
I'M NOT DRAGGING YOU INTO
THAT --
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: THAT'S TERRIFIC, I
KNOW YOU CONDEMNED THAT
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
SINCE THE BIG FACE-OFF WITH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
CALIFORNIA IS SITTING ON LARGE
COMPANY, 3 MILLION PEOPLE,
REVOLT AGAINST THAT.
DO YOU BLAME ORANGE COUNTY FOR
VOTING THE WAY THEY DID GIVEN
THAT THEY DON'T WANT
ORANGE COUNTY TO TURN INTO
SAN FRANCISCO, MEANING, THEY
DON'T WANT TO HYPODERMIC NEEDLES
IN THE STREETS, THEY DON'T WANT
THE HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM, AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO CRIME, THEY
DON'T WANT ONE SAN FRANCISCO HAS
CLEMENT DOUBLED THE RATE OF THE
STATE CRIME RATE.
>> IN SAN FRANCISCO'S DEFENSE,
WE DON'T WANT ANY OF THAT STUFF
EITHER.
BUT AS FAR AS WHAT ORANGE COUNTY
IS DOING, THIS, I THINK, IS JUST
ANOTHER POLITICAL STUNT.
IT'S A LOT LIKE WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING.
I QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THE
SUPERVISOR'S RESOLUTION WILL GET
PAST THE ATTORNEYS ON THIS.
THE LAWSUIT THAT WAS FOLLOWED BY
I.C.E. WAS FILED ON PREEMPTION
ISSUES, THAT THE FEDERAL LAW
PREEMPTS STATE LAW, I THINK THAT
LAW HAS BEEN SETTLED.
NOBODY IS ARGUING THAT STATE LAW
PREEMPTS FEDERAL LAW.
I THINK WHAT THE FEDS ARE SAYING
IS THAT WE ARE INTERFERING BY
TELLING OUR CITIZENS AND BY
TELLING OUR STATE
REPRESENTATIVES NOT TO ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAW, AND I THINK THE
ONLY WAY THE DEFENSE IS GOING TO
WIN ON THAT ARGUMENT IS IF THERE
IS SOME SORT OF FEDERAL ARGUMENT
ATTACHED TO IT, OTHERWISE I
DON'T SEE A WAY OF WINNING IT.
AS FAR AS ORANGE COUNTY IS
CONCERNED, THEY DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION HERE BECAUSE
PREEMPTION IS NOT THEIR
ARGUMENT.
>> Laura: IF WE GET INTO
PREEMPTION, WE'LL LOSE THE
ENTIRE VIEWING AUDIENCE HERE.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO THE NUT OF
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
WE HAVE A RESOLUTION IN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT NOW REQUIRES
THAT YOU ANNOUNCE, MICHELE,
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG --    --
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG --    -Y
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG --    -U
ANNOUNCE WHEN A PRISONER IS
RELEASED, CORRECT?
YOU ANNOUNCE IT SO PEOPLE KNOW
WHEN THEY WILL BE RELEASED.
WHY WOULD ANYONE BE AGAINST THAT
WHY WOULD ANYONE BE AGAINST THA
THAT?
>> THE LAST THREE MONTHS, WE HAD
172 CRIMINAL ALIENS WHO WERE
RELEASED ON THE STREET.
AS A SUPERVISOR, I ALREADY TOLD
YOU, AND IT'S THE PUBLIC SAFETY
THAT COMES FIRST.
IMMIGRATION IS UNDER FEDERAL
LAW, AND THEN THIS IS TOTALLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAW IN THE
STATE THAT THEY JUST CREATED.
THEY CREATED CHAOS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WORKING TOGETHER.
SO THIS ONE HAS TO BE STOPPED.
THAT'S THE REASON THAT